this program shows drugs being made sold
and used it features graphic content
that may not be suitable for all
audiences viewer discretion is advised
[Music]
a junkie
escort that's how i marketed
as a slamming
uh leather
that's what i have to be if i want to
keep the money coming
i have to have more drugs like i'm
panicking right now because this is
gonna be the last of it right here
[Music]
colby has been using crystal meth for 13
years
now he injects himself three times a day
i should about half a gram at a time
most people that do that would be just
like out of their mind
[Music]
it usually doesn't cost me too much
because i usually trade my
ass for drugs
if i had to buy it probably about 150 a
day
it's um
it's like pure ecstasy over your whole
body and you immediately just feel like
really sexual and like just really
just like an animal
a lot of gay people do it to just have
sex parties
it's easy to find in the gay community
if i want to do it i just offer to have
sex with
who knows who cares
[Music]
the epicenter of the 60s psychedelic
revolution
san francisco is notorious for drugs
[Music]
[Applause]
but in the new millennium the summer of
love has become the winter of addiction
and in the heart of the city the gay
community is struggling to recover from
a meth epidemic
[Music]
it's all over the streets
you can get it anywhere
an entire subculture known as party and
play is based around methamphetamine use
gay websites are used to arrange
meetings with strangers to take crystal
meth and have sex
sometimes for days on end
i get on five different websites and
i'll just go from one to the next
you see an ad and it's got the t
capitalized and you know that they're
partying or whatever if it says blowing
clouds which is smoking it let's get to
the point it means that they're into
slamming it
and it's usually always associated with
sex
[Music]
colby is hiv positive
but his life still revolves around sex
and meth
there's just something about it goes
hand in hand with
being gay
i can't remember the last time i've had
sex without it
it's almost ready
colby charges 200 an hour specializing
in the most extreme fetishes there's a
guy i know he sends me money just for
drugs sometimes a thousand dollars at a
time but he wants it always spent on
crystal man
i in exchange make videos of me shooting
up
that's what turns him on the most
he spends his earnings on drugs and
lives homeless on the street
only renting a room when he needs to
shoot a video
here we go
in low doses meth increases energy
i didn't get all of it
i don't waste it either
[Applause]
in higher doses it can induce euphoria
extremely like hot hot feeling
um
i feel good
i'm gonna try to get the rest of this in
that was a big one
the initial high is known as the rush
normally i would be playing with myself
that's what i generally do right after
i usually have
guys around
once the rush has subsided i'm very
antsy like i get very antsy i don't want
it i can't sit still
the adrenaline-like effects kick in
i have a lot of energy right now i just
find this
oh man i just
my head
my mouth is like extremely dry all of a
sudden
my head hurt
just a little bit with keeping it like
three days you can't eat you can't sleep
oh i've been up for eight days before
as the meth takes hold
addicts lives fall apart i used to make
straight a's
i was always like student of the year
didn't do any drugs
went to church all the time
now i am homeless
a prostitute
a major junkie
it's out of control it's like i cannot
stop
[Music]
it's killing me
that destroys lives man
but that's the choice they make
the asian cartel has been poisoning san
francisco with meth for almost 25 years
we started the shab movement here in the
bay area
and it all started really in south the
market
we were the first ones to get the
process done
before they just had like a lot of raw
crank we would process it take it
through a vacuum pump
clean it wash it and it came out like
shards you had one shard that was like
probably as big as a plate
once cooked the asian cartel's product
is distributed by car to one of their
six safe houses within the city
the areas that we pretty much take care
of you know the tenderloin south of
market
the sunset
the richmond area
san francisco's 44 asian so
we have a big market here
we're 50 strong in this one particular
operation
and we're all over the city
the asian cartel run two meth super labs
in the city
one is over 10 000 square feet
they're producing
20 30 pounds a week
the amount of money that they're making
is pretty large
anywhere from a million to three
in san francisco's meth trade there's
very little peace and love
out of
dealers maybe two
will survive through all the
that's if they're really really lucky
[Music]
we're about our bread as long as you
don't put our money then we're good with
you we ain't got no problems with you
[Music]
like ninjas of the american underworld
the asian cartel prefers to remain
hidden in the shadows
we don't stand on the street corner
that's just not who we are
that to us is just sheer stupidity
you get the guy
he might get caught with like an eighth
and pretty soon he's gonna start giving
him
why go to the pen when you can send a
friend
that's the ideology of other races
that's not our ideology
but if you have a good shards or good
shabu or good glass your product speaks
for itself
you all need to look for clients
but the asian cartel's grip on san
francisco's meth trade is under threat
the secret of their cooking process has
gotten into the wrong hands
a couple of our guys showed some of the
mexicans on how to cook
which it all looked for all of us the
mexican cartel they just cut through the
chase and they just started making
crystal on their own
now the mexican cartels are intent on
taking over
super labs hidden in the depths of
mexico have perfected the process of
industrial meth production
flooding the streets of san francisco
with super strength meth
at a fraction of the cost
chronic metheus is on the move
once the party drug populated the rave
scene
crystal meth is now so cheap it's
replacing crack as the favorite high of
the down and out
only a few miles from the castro
hordes of meth addicts gather in one of
the worst drug ghettos in the whole of
america
the tenderloin
francisco has a significant drug problem
you only need to walk through the
tenderloin to see that
[Music]
it's probation's job to keep recently
released prisoners on the straight and
narrow
but in a city saturated with meth
it's not easy
a lot of our clients hang out in the
tenderloin
so yeah we spend a lot of time rolling
around to see if we can make contact
the average age is about 40. majority of
them are male
and so they have had a long history of
substance abuse
today christy and david are scouring the
tenderloin for a recently released meth
addict who's failed to turn up for his
treatment this is one of the blocks
where there's a lot of illegal narcotic
action
we see a lot of hand-to-hand sales going
on it's really saturated
[Music]
a 50-block area right in the heart of
downtown san francisco the tenderloin
has long been a notoriously violent drug
supermarket
but few drugs have caused as much mayhem
as meth
and the tenderloin is plumbing new
depths
we've seen an increase in clients that
are addicted to methamphetamine the new
strandon on the street is very addictive
and it's causing them to have extreme
paranoia
christie's department is feeling the
effects of the recent flood of extra
potent mexican meth on the market
they'll come in convinced that
somebody's following them trying to kill
them and there's really no calming them
down
so it's really difficult to navigate
that psychosis
as a probation officer christie has seen
the horrific effects that even
short-term methods can have on the body
some of our clients develop sores on
their face from scratching physically
it's a very uh damaging drug
hair gets brittle and they gloss their
teeth
it's literally like zombies
and like zombies the denizens of the
tenderloin come alive at night
[Music]
he just took a hit right here on the
block
and you can go up this street and you'll
see
lighters going
all of them standing out here taking
their last little hits
some of them picked up off the ground
don't know whatever it is they tweaking
so hard out here
somebody told me when i first moved here
a couple months ago people don't come
here to live they come here to die
i'm hoping that i don't make that
statistic true you know
i got my addictions and it's tough out
here
[Music]
a lot of us being tricked in thinking i
think it's selling dope and all of that
is american dream it's not it's feeding
our penal system
that's the only outlet that we have
it's the sale of drugs prostitution for
the women drugs for the men
this is destruction of the whole
community right here
this footage from a safe house in the
heart of the tenderloin was shot by a
gang member
let's kill that dog
that's i'll be really honey
that's great a product man you see that
that money
on the street this pound of crystallized
mexican super meth is worth almost 100
000.
you got these plain this is wonderful
[Music]
heading up a sizable operation is chi
i'm manufacturing crane
christian
cheese i mean whatever you choose to
call it i'm got a nice little operation
going on here
[Music]
crews like cheese are receiving
industrial-strength raw meth from mexico
which they manufacture into crystals
a process known as re-rocking
you got miners crying
they churn out 10 to 15 pounds every
single week
much to some guy's mind below it's
enough for us money
it's enough to supply not just the
tenderloin but also daly city
the largest city in neighboring san
mateo county
we're doing that on a weekly basis man
you're getting a hundred thousand about
it man only minimum
it depends on how we serve it right but
bottom line man uh we don't see them six
digits we don't see nothing else right
because that's what we're striving for
an operation like this requires some
serious muscle we got 15 to 20 plus on
the payroll that's about the size of our
models 15 to 20 of us but uh
born into the drug trade she puts a
success down to experience
that's what i was wanting to do this is
all i haven't known
it's all i was up and raised and all
i've ever seen in life so uh
i guess so that's why i make me so good
at what i do man that's why we eating
around here
[Music]
by using crews like cheese to flood the
streets with cheap industrial super meth
the mexican cartels have succeeded in
creating a whole new market for their
product
to supply their new market the mexican
cartels have established a drug
superhighway
that runs from the mexican border
towards the bay area
injecting meth right into the heart of
san francisco
but there's one choke point and that's
where sergeant bonzel is waiting
i would say
95 to 98 of the methamphetamine in this
area comes from mexico across the
border a bunch of copies and i'm headed
back to our location
sergeant bonzel and his team are working
to infiltrate and disrupt the cartel's
distribution network
it's painstaking and risky
today we're
strictly doing surveillance on a
mid-level distributor
this particular target is picking up
anywhere from a pound to a half a pound
of methamphetamine every three days
today we're just trying to make our
suspect go into the door that we believe
that he's living
the cops suspect the dealer is using his
transgender roommate's apartment as a
stash house
according to our source
he's putting out about four thousand
dollars every three days
so he's probably making a couple grand
profit a week
so he's paying his bills
[Music]
if the cops can confirm that this is
where the dealer is staying a judge will
issue a warrant for a raid
the sergeant also has intel on the
dealer's car
copy i got four
6 20.
we're expecting an arrival of a black
mercedes um that our target drives it's
not here at the target location now so
we're just waiting
to get this information the team have
already flipped a lower level dealer
the sergeant is hoping that busting this
dealer will take them even higher
our main objective
is to go up the ladder
eventually it'll work to the cell boss
of the cartel whoever's providing those
narcotics down the line
he may be only a mid-level dealer but
bonzel suspects that he could lead them
all the way to the sinaloa cartel
the cineloans use the same
organizational structure as terrorists
they're very organized there might be 15
cells of cartel dealers in northern
california
each one of those cells will
have contact with the cartel across the
border but each cell may not know that
the other cell's operating
this makes them almost impossible to
stamp out
if one cell is caught it cannot give
evidence on another
that cartel in mexico is sending
hundreds of pounds of methamphetamine to
these cells to distribute throughout all
of northern california
despite being 500 miles from mexico
the bay area is still very much cartel
turf
you definitely have cartel connected
people at the top running these um cells
in these organizations on this side of
the border we can keep them out of our
area or make it hard for them to operate
in our area
that's our
goal copy no change go ahead
the dealer's black mercedes is not
showing
it is now
almost 5 15.
we've been sitting in these cars for the
past six and a half hours
with not much action
just as the cops are on the verge of
calling it a night there's a sign of
activity the point you copy
is out
you should have her walk in a southbound
black sweater i think of a red shirt
black pants blonde hair
first defector
see that mercedes coming in
then within minutes the black mercedes
arrives
target vehicles pulling into the
driveway now
we got our driver's side door open
it's critical the team get a 100 id
so the sergeant sends a detective in on
foot
hood up for disguise
but if the target gets suspicious it
could blow the entire operation
firm you have eyes on the suspect
let's uh make the door and we're good
okay i got him going
after nine hours of surveillance the
team can finally link the suspect to
this address
took a lot longer than we thought it was
going to take but our search warrant is
ironclad we have to make sure that we
get somebody else behind bars
[Music]
for the moment the drug superhighway
remains wide open
and raw supermeth from mexico is pouring
into the bay area
once the meth is re-rocked in local
stash houses it's distributed to street
dealers back in the tenderloin
my office is located on the corner of
turkey network and i guess you could say
my job
is make money and get high
[Music]
i buy wholesale and i sell retail
buyer who's been dealing in the
tenderloin for over 30 years
what i do is called supply and demand i
supply what's in demand and that's how i
survive
his career has followed drug trends in
the 80s he sold coke in the 90s
it was crack
in the 2000s he slung smack
nowadays he's shifting more and more
crystal meth
what we have here is a bag of crystal
they call it tt here in san francisco
crystal meth it's one of the cheapest
products out there
bayou pays 800 for half an ounce at
wholesale
and make 700 profit
dealing funds bayous crippling
addictions to crack
meth and heroin
i spent 300 inhabit
this piece here
is what i choose to call my personal
because i want nobody to get this one
here this is one in my
buttocks they say once you go black you
don't go back
look at that look pretty
like a pretty woman
now you see it
now you don't
but
like most dealers in the tenderloin he's
working just to keep the withdrawals at
bay
if i could have a breakfast this would
be my breakfast
breakfast on the bureau i'll call it
that's pretty much what my life consists
of i spoke up hope
and i get money
with the streets of san francisco awash
with mexican supermeth the number of
addicts and dealers is higher than ever
san francisco is pioneering a new system
called the realignment
street-level drug criminals remain in
the community where they are encouraged
through treatment into jobs by probation
officers like christy
and tommy
we approach it with a social work
philosophy
at the same time we have to be concerned
for our safety
with the new strain of supermeth on the
streets users can be more irrational and
violent than ever today christie and
tommy are hunting down a meth addict
who's failed to turn up for his
treatment we don't know what we're going
to encounter we don't know who else is
in the room all the officers in my unit
will be armed
most probationers are housed in cheap
hotels in the tenderloin right back in
the middle of the drug hell many are
trying to escape
hey morning
do you have anything in here you're not
supposed to have
oh name some stuff i'm not
paraphernalia
i got you sweetheart i'll take it from
here
got some needles and a little tie off
there
a little push
this torch
this is the lighter yeah but what are
you using it for
what are my cigarettes
so when's the last time you used
about two days ago okay
my issue is that i can't let the
taxpayers think that we're providing a
free room to you so that you can just
get hive so if you want to gather up
your stuff from the shower here we're
gonna you're gonna go down there with us
sir
i was gonna take you to jail i'd tell
you that
under the new system the probation
officers are on a mission to get him off
drugs
not back in a cell
we're going to take them over to the
department of public health and get them
into some outpatient treatment today
like many of san francisco's street
addicts he switched from crack to meth
to get more bang for his buck
the crack was no longer getting me high
she's getting me sick which makes me
sick make my stomach hurt now
it's all garbage
[Music]
most people are
using drugs to shield the pain
i've lost everybody in my family i have
no living members that know where i'm at
they don't even know if i'm dead or
alive
and uh you know i did 10 years like 10
years without having anybody on the
planet to send me a stamp to say that we
give a red ass about you
despite his addiction david is free to
go
he's going to start outpatient treatment
so we feel confident that he's going to
address his substance abuse issue
and in turn he'll get to stay in his
room
while the probation department throws
out a lifeline
most people caught up in san francisco's
drug trade believe there is no escape
i think i'll never get out the ghetto
i might be stuck here for the rest of my
life
i might just die down here who knows
it's hard down here
[Music]
spider works the tenderloin
collecting money for a drug dealer
people they don't pay
i rough them up
i might get my black eye or break their
jaw
break a finger arm
it don't matter
for just 500 a month
spider has sold his soul there's a
couple of people had to chase down and i
don't like to run
if i run and i catch you it's gonna be
worser
you don't have it i got to break
something
he's been working the tenderloins drug
trade since he was 12. when i was young
i used to watch my mother sell drugs and
i just grew into it
i didn't see people get shot out here
obviously people get stabbed i saw the
police get beat up
i see people just go crazy
[Applause]
i've seen people down the street with
needles and they are i see people die
with crack pipe in their mouth be their
last hit and the heart just stopped i've
seen it seem wrong
many people in the tenderloin have lost
at least one loved one to the drug trade
and spider is no exception
man was coming to make a purchase on
some drugs
he came back and shot my best friend
right in front of my face
shot the wrong person
that took a lot out of me
think about him all the time
but life is cheap in the tenderloin and
it doesn't take much to spark a murder
it could have been 5 or 10 20 who knows
i don't know
50 miles south of san francisco sergeant
bonzel has received some urgent intel on
their meth dealer
our suspect got in a fight with his
roommate so the roommate kicked him out
bonzel has no choice but to execute the
search warrant a day early we just don't
want to take the chance of losing our
crook
they must raid the stash house before
their suspect disappears
[Music]
i'll be uh coming from east to west
sergeant bonzel and his team plan to
fake a routine traffic stop on the meth
dealer's car there's our marked unit
right here
and we'll be making the car stop for us
[Music]
once they've stopped the car
they should find methane
copy then point state where you're at
and i'll be there
30 seconds
this will give them probable cause to
raid the suspected stash house
[Music]
we're waiting for our suspect to leave
the house so we can make this car stop
we would like to make the car stop a few
blocks away from here
that way if anybody else that he knew
came by they won't see him
we want it to look like this is a lucky
car stop and the guy found narcotics
it's all to protect the informant
by using a traffic stop as a cover
bonzel hopes to hide the fact that an
informant has led them to the stash
house
duffel bag mercedes he's putting the
duffel bag into the trunk of the machine
and he's getting ready to leave the
mercedes so
that's good news
looks like he's away southbound
[Music]
but the plan's already gone wrong
okay the stop was made right there
as soon as he saw the marked unit the
suspect pulled over
forcing the officer to arrest him right
outside his apartment
hey i may have provided the lady man on
foot
our transvestite roommate is walking
around the corner right now
by chance the suspect's transgender
roommate has stumbled across the scene
our worry is that the roommate will go
into the apartment and start flushing
any evidence that might still be
upstairs
hey where you at
copy it is confirmed on the roommate she
did notice that that is the target's car
parked there
she just turned around and headed back
towards the apartment
police fear that if the roommate returns
to the apartment she will destroy
evidence
right now we have actual circumference
okay all right
now their cover is blown they need to
move on the apartment and fast behind
the building attack up and then
hit the house
any police entry into a meth dealer's
house is risky
they are often armed and dangerous
[Music]
looks like it has already been raided
now the search can begin
in the bedroom just out in plain view we
have found a line of what appears to be
crystal methamphetamine
prepared to be snorted
the team also discovers a hide
but it's empty
safe
were you able to talk him into a safe
code
they desperately need to find more
evidence to build a case at this point
we're waiting for a narcotics canine to
come and give us direction where to
search and see if we don't miss anything
oh boy affirmative on a hit on the safe
okay he hit on the safe he gave him
what's called a positive alert on the
safe meaning there is narcotics or was
narcotics and safe at one point
the dealer has denied any knowledge of
the safe
the team is running out of options
then a breakthrough
in the suspect's car they find a hidden
compartment so we got his money here in
the height of the vehicle
one bankroll
looks like we got another
spindle of cash
oh boy
it's a narc dog dog not trained to hit
on money it's trying to hit on narcotics
so obviously this money's been hand in
hand with narcotics
unless they find a decent quantity of
meth
this dealer will probably walk
[Music]
this was in the suspect's uh backpack
and you pull it off and you have a hide
and just right off the bat you have a
methamphetamine pipe
we have his baggies
that are going to be used to package the
methamphetamine for sales
and then you have the bulk
we like to call his stash
the methamphetamine that he has packaged
for sale
finally they have enough to put the
suspect behind bars
[Music]
okay
it's like we've got a pretty decent
amount but i think we're gonna find more
in the safe that he says he doesn't know
anything about
back at the station
the team finds another use for the
battering ram
what is that
there's possible chemicals in there
anytime we open up the unknown and
there's liquid in there we're dealing
with methamphetamine we're concerned
that there's um chemicals
the chemicals involved in meth
production are extremely toxic it's a
meth pipe a myth meth water bomb
that that fluid will test positive for
methamphetamine that pretty heavy smell
let's get this out of this
enclosed room
it looks like this dealer has been icing
small amounts of raw meth
coupled with the crystal they found
bagged up for sale
it's a useful bust
there's a gram
they charge about 10 a point and a gram
is 10 points
this is 48.
i think it could be up to
5 000 worth of narcotics here
we'll see if this will lead us to more
for bonsall and his team
this dealer could be a crucial link to
the top of the chain
the cartel's sale boss if we're able to
get this person's source we would expect
to find multiple pounds
and then his guy will have multiple
kilos and
that should lead us to the border
while the cops chased the sinaloa
cartel's shadow
san francisco's asian cartel is
diversifying to capitalize on the
mexican takeover
we have a pretty good relationship with
the mexicans
offering cartels like the sinaloa access
to their distribution network
at a price
we have our own shipping our own courier
service but we'll charge you two
thousand dollars per p
to get to its destination we just know
people at the airport you know people at
the cargo ships we ship out to new york
florida chicago
and there's quite a few other places as
well
the sinaloa cartel's aggressive
expansion into san francisco is part of
a long-term plan
the domination of the entire u.s crystal
meth market
it's much easier to sell out there
because the bay area everything is
saturated everybody's got crystal out
here
the iceman has carved out his own niche
i could be dirty for like 30 minutes and
all you are is a go-to guy kind of like
the middle marriage just making things
happen
of course you get stuff intercepted
that's part of the game
you can lose a batch every now and then
for every batch lost a dozen make it
through
the iceman now gets a cut of business
worth billions
if you're shipping you can make five
hundred thousand dollars in one month
it's night and day
while the cartel is raking the money the
addicts on the street pay the price
[Music]
colby's last meth binge ended in a
severe come down
i haven't been high in five days and
i've been asleep the entire time
oh god it's been horrible i have been
uncontrollably crying for no reason
really disoriented and dizzy
forced into cold turkey by lack of funds
colby has just received payment for his
last hardcore video
i'm just now starting to feel better
from detoxing from the drugs
but
i'm gonna start the cycle all over again
even after the come down has passed
long-term users can remain severely
depressed and lethargic for up to a year
for many the solution is to get back on
the meth as quick as they can
180 all right
and
there he is
so
that's my dealer he has the drugs ready
and he's about eight blocks down the
street
so i'm very excited
and like i feel high already just now
just thinking about it
so
colby knows he should take this
opportunity to quit i was having second
thoughts because i feel good it's been a
long time since i've actually detoxed
[Music]
and today i was starting to feel better
i could change my mind right now
[Music]
should i
no
given the choice of feeling suicidal or
feeling high
for most addicts the choice is obvious
it took about 20 seconds and i
ended up with this
it's an eight ball it's about three and
a half grams
when you're homeless like colby it's
easier to score the drugs
than it is to find a place to inject
them
i'm going to go into this outdoor toilet
here and get high
it's very very hard to get privacy when
you're homeless
now we gotta watch out for that cleaning
cycle where is that needle that's a used
one
oh shoot
definitely not the most hygienic place
to do this
it's very nerve-wracking knowing that
there's hundreds of people right outside
the store
here we go much anticipated
please don't
clog oh
it's starting the cleaning cycle do we
need to get out
the toilet folded up and water was about
to start gushing everywhere you can hear
it in there
and i came out with a syringe in my
mouth
colby decides to head to the castro
to find somewhere quieter to shoot up
they're always
locked
with so many meth heads around in this
city
everyone locks their porta-potties
yeah it's locked
it's not
forcing addicts to shoot up in the most
desperate of places
i'm so freaking paranoid
i should not be doing this at a church
but
the sirens going off
[Music]
oh what a life
that burned that time
my heart's going 90 to nothing
without the cravings clouding his mind
colby realizes what his life has become
if my friends and family saw me pulled
up in this little
corner here shooting up
it would probably break their hearts
but
this drug is just it's
it's gotten a hold of me you know
i love it i hate it
[Music]
you